[Music]
part of the journey is the end I know I
said no more surprises but I was really
hoping to pull off one last one
this job try to save as many people as
we can sometimes that doesn't mean
everybody the world has changed we are
at war
in time you know what it's like to lose
to feel so desperately that you're right
yet to fail all the same the entire time
when youth panels he only ever had one
goal to bring balance to the universe by
wiping out half of our
Avengers they hope they remember you
even if there's a small chance
we owe this
everyone who's not in this room to try
we lost all of us lost friends lost
family
if you lost part of ourselves
this is the fight of our lives
doc now
all of us
we do nothing you will destroy our
sometimes the best we can do
there was no other way
this is your chance it's time about
saving our world
it's about saving Pierce
services it
super No
no way we all get through this we had no
plans tomorrow night what do we do we
fight
stay down final one
is near
this is our end everything goes
some people
-
[Music]